worked as a CIA case officer from 1998
to 2003 she tells her story in the new
book blowing my cover this program is 40
minutes hello thank you for coming I'm
bill O'Sullivan I'm a features editor at
The Washingtonian magazine and I'd like
to welcome you to the Washingtonians is
a monthly reading and discussion series
celebrating local author area bookstore
in DC Maryland or Virginia as well as a
live chat on our website Washingtonian
online tonight's reading Q&A and signing
will be followed by an online chat with
Lindsay Moran tomorrow at 2 p.m. that's
at Washingtonian comments I think I said
if you think of a question you forgot to
ask or if you have friends who weren't
able to make it tonight you can join the
chat tomorrow at 2:00 and you can even
start submitting questions as soon as
you get home you can find out more about
the book club on our website and get on
our email list if you join the club
you're automatically entered in a
monthly drawing to win $100 gift
certificate at the bookstore posting
that month's event and the next drawing
will be February 1st our next event will
be Tuesday February 22nd with
Washingtonian lifestyle editor lesley
milk author of the forthcoming book it's
her wedding but I'll cry if I want to a
Survival Guide for the mother of the
bride it's a very funny book actually
that will be at the Bethesda Barnes &
Noble at 7:30 followed by an online chat
the next day before we begin I'd like to
thank Barnes and Noble
the Georgetown Barnes & Noble for
hosting this event with The
Washingtonian the other night I was at
the gym flipping channels at my exercise
machine and I came across a Lindsay
Moran being interviewed by Bill O'Reilly
and I thought well if she can survive
him she can surely tonight will be a
piece of cake or actually if she
survived being a CIA case officer Bill
O'Reilly was a piece of cake Lindsay is
a freelance writer whose work has
appeared in The New York Times The
Washington Post USA Today and the
Washingtonians last year she wrote a
piece for us about why women make better
spies than men she worked for the CIA
from 1998 to 2003 and has written a
funny surprisingly Frank and very
entertaining book
about the experience please welcome
Lindsay Moran very suspicious I brought
my own water um thank you bill thank you
very much and yeah in fact it was in
Washingtonians
I guess formally blew my cover by
writing that article why women make
better spies that from what I understand
did not go over too well with men at the
CIA thank you all for coming out this is
really exciting for me I'm only going to
talk for a second and then I'm going to
do a couple of readings from the book
and then I'll just open it up to some
questions the book pretty much explains
why I joined the agency and what
happened to me there and why I left the
agency so I'm not going to get into that
too much but I did want to talk a little
bit about why I wrote this book and what
kind of book I hoped it would be I'm the
kind of person who's always been
fascinated with intelligence from a vet
from about the age of six or seven and
read any spy novel or CIA memoir that I
could get my hands on and they tend to
be generally big thick and quite serious
tomes books on intelligence and I wanted
to write something that people who were
not Intel wonks would want to read so I
wrote blowing my cover very deliberately
with a kind of cheeky tone that I hoped
would appeal to a much wider audience
and I'm going to read two segments from
the book and they're from different
parts the first one takes place when I
was still in training down at the CIA's
facility near Williamsburg called the
farm and we went through kind of a long
arduous training process and part of
that training process was a class that
we called crash and burn which was
basically a defensive driving class I
had never been any stellar dry
to begin with and suddenly I found
myself zigzagging in Reverse through
orange cones and taking high-speed turns
and all kinds of Dukes of Hazzard esque
moves so this passage actually describes
a little bit of part of that course let
me just take a sip of water
I might stop a couple of times to
explain who people are if I refer to
them the second week of crash-and-burn
consisted of smashing old beater
Cadillacs and Monte Carlos probably
seized from drug dealers through
barriers such as parked cars wooden
fences and solid walls the instructor
would let fall a flag like Natalie Wood
in rebel without a cause and from a
standstill the student was expected to
floor the gas and drive unflinchingly
into a barricade the point was to
demonstrate that indeed we could collide
into a number of different obstructions
and still live when it was my turn to
launch head-on into two parked cars I
actually shut my eyes at the moment of
impact I opened them a couple of seconds
later stunned to discover myself alive
and well and beyond the wreckage of the
barricade after four days of slamming
into large stationary objects we were
told to prepare for a nighttime exercise
to me any activity that took place after
dark and didn't involve martinis was
ominous and unpleasant for one thing the
whole base had the aura of some southern
backwater when I talked about the base
I'm referring to the farm which was kind
of like a military base the whole base
had the aura of some southern backwater
where small slightly ethnic people like
me might get lynched or Bubba raped
after nightfall I hardly looked forward
to incorporating darkness into our
already harrowing demolition exercises
that night we convened in a large
classroom near one of the many firing
ranges ostensibly to take a test on our
knowledge of explosives which had been
the topic of a single day seminar
earlier that week while we were
completing the multiple-choice
explosives explosives exam a trio of
instructors would arrive and select a
single student to take outside those who
returned about 20 minutes later would
resume their tests and as per
instructions not utter a word I had a
vague idea of what was in store when I
caught a
glimpse of tornado Sally being
blindfolded outside the door as its
slowly swung shut tornado Sally was one
of my fellow trainees and we called her
that because she was kind of a whirlwind
of ineptitude but um but a great girl
and I think a fun character in the book
when it was my turn to go my heart was
racing
blindfolded I was positioned in the
front passenger seat of one of the
beat-up cars the instructor reversed out
then drove fast for about two minutes
when the car stopped
I heard the doors open and I was told to
slide over into the driver's seat as the
instructor took his place next to me in
the passenger seat okay drive on he said
still blindfolded I accelerated slowly
giving my anxiety ample time to mount
while the instructor told me when to
turn right or left
finally commanding me to halt he pulled
my blindfold off we had stopped at a
border crossing where various
instructors dressed as border guards
wielded weapons and enormous flashlights
jorge an instructor who'd spent his
career in latin america moved toward the
car shined his flashlight in my eyes and
demanded something of me in spanish a
language I don't speak or understand I
assumed given the border motif that he
wanted my passport and so I provided my
base badge which weeks earlier we had
been told would serve as identification
in any simulated frontier or hostage
situations I surmise that this was a
simulated frontier situation meanwhile I
looked around frantically for some way
to escape something through which I
might crash the car then I remembered
that we've been given a lot of
instruction on just keeping our wits
about us talking our way through
difficult situations and avoiding any
rash or unnecessary maneuvers just
because we learned how to evel knievel
our way through an impasse didn't mean
we were supposed to do it in every
situation this seemed to me one of those
scenarios from which I could emerge
without doing donuts or barreling
through a brick wall Jorge was
haranguing me by this point about my
peso Porto
something along the lines of it was
non-authentic otoko and also saying
something about narcotic Oh another
instructor was meticulously examining
the front bumper and hood of my car
still I didn't think the solution was to
run him over I soon gathered drawing
upon the fact that Jorge was dangling a
ziplock baggie full of dirt and onion
weed in my face that this was about to
become a trumped-up drug charge
I had no bribe money with me and half
thought such a gesture would only invite
more trouble I kept repeating americano
americano diplomat oh I felt like a
deranged Starbucks customer trying to
make my order clear to the
uncomprehending barista I was told to
unlock the door so Jorge and the others
could search the car's interior from
which no surprise they managed to
unearth more Ziploc baggies these
containing white powder I calmly denied
knowledge of the drugs I can only assume
my defense was less than convincing it's
just an exercise I told myself while
something nagged at the back of my mind
a disquieting seed had been planted and
further training would provide endless
fertilizer am I really going to be able
to handle myself when faced with such a
situation in real life confronted with
damning evidence genuine or fabricated
by armed foreigners would I indeed be
able to keep my wits about me or what I
crumble blow my cover and panic and
desperately insist on calling the
Ambassador or worse the CIA chief to
rescue my sorry apprehended ass finally
Jorge either tired of my performance or
decided I'd objected willfully enough to
suggest that I was neither going to
admit to smuggling nor go commando
through the frontier he handed me back
my passport and pulled aside the wooden
Pony barrier to let me drive on later I
found out that a few students including
tornado sally had completely freaked as
soon as their blindfolds were removed
and careened through the barricade as
Jorge and the other instructors lept
out of their paths once through the
frontier I was blindfolded again and
told to drive on several more minutes of
sight
navigation ended with the instructor
commanding me to stop and then pulling
the blindfold off my face again this
time I was parked astoundingly in a sort
of cul-de-sac formed by a six-foot tall
brick wall a gang of masked men began
launching themselves over the wall
landing with echoing thumps on the hood
of my car and banging on the windshield
you'd think I'd be used to the
instructor turned Banshee routine by now
but my stomach cinched tight luckily I'd
remembered to lock the car doors after
Jorge and the gang had checked for drugs
the masked man grabbed futile II at the
door handles continued to beat on the
hood and scream unintelligibly pressing
their wild eyed grimacing faces against
the windshield
observing that the car was surrounded on
all sides except the rear I quickly
figured out the point of this exercise
I threw the car in reverse and eyes
fixed on the rearview mirror flew
backward until there was enough distance
to make a three-point turn and blow dust
in the air as I tore out of there no
sooner had I caught my breath and the
blindfold was back over my eyes I prayed
that we would be heading back to the
classroom now that I could finish my
explosives exam and return to the
barracks to collapse in my bunk I was
sore tired and stressed out from two
weeks of sitting in a car all day
high-speed chasing maneuvering on two
wheels screeching to halts and craning
my neck to weave among orange cones on
the one hand I felt proud acutely aware
that my limits were being tested and
that I was rising to each occasion on
the other hand I wondered what the hell
am I doing with my life at some point
didn't I just want to find a nice guy
and settle down drag racer demolition
girl here would have to start cruising
monster truck rallies for dates I
relegated these thoughts to the back of
my mind as I concentrated on the task at
hand
driving blindfold through the woods I
was told to stop the car again and this
time as soon as the blindfold was off a
new gang of baton brandishing thugs
emerged from the darkness and commenced
the now hackneyed theme of beating on
the car and shrieking obscenities one of
them had an ak-47 which he shot off
merrily into the air
I was no longer scared so much as amused
though later I heard one of the trainees
wet his pants
the instructors I figured must be having
the time of their lives the farm it
occurred to me was all part of an
elaborate game for men who'd never
really grown up and the world of
espionage
I thought wearily might well just be a
global playing field of this little boys
game this time I was just I discerned
that I was surrounded on all sides
except in front where to park sedans
formed a barricade one of the attackers
had somehow managed to get the back door
open and he was crawling in when I
thrust my foot down on the accelerator
just as I'd practiced all week I headed
straight for the weakest point in the
barrier the joint where the two cars in
my path met bumper-to-bumper
sure enough I broke through to the other
side turning briefly to see the vehicles
through which I just smashed now with
their headlights facing forward and a
large smouldering gap between them I
pushed down the gas pedal as far as it
would go and barrel through the woods
the instructor whupping alongside of me
you go girl
exhilarated I thought this may be a
silly game but I'm actually getting good
at it take some water that was one of
the few parts of my training that came
in handy later I'm a much better driver
the second portion that I'm going to
read takes place later in the book when
I've already finished my training and
I'm a full fledged
spy and I'm overseas here in Macedonia
meeting late at night in a car with a
potential foreign asset it's Friday
night in the Balkans and I am sitting in
a parked car with an older man the
windows are steamed up and rain falls in
torrents around us it's impossible to
see anything outside save the occasional
blurry beam of passing headlights that
always causes my heart to seize up the
man a Serb smells of cigarettes and
looks worn out by years of drinking and
Jen
discontent he squeezed himself into the
passenger seat and with his lumpy brown
trenchcoat and modeled face he looks
like a large sprouting potato you'd
forgotten at the bottom of the pantry a
few minutes earlier I had picked him up
at the rear exit of a shopping mall a
mile away before that I spent two hours
driving around just like in training to
make sure I wasn't being followed in
training they always cautioned us you
have to be a hundred percent sure you're
clean otherwise abort the operation I've
been doing this spying thing for months
now and I've realized you can never be a
hundred percent sure still my eyes are
trained to dart around at all times even
when I'm doing everyday errands or just
out for a walk I'm constantly on the
lookout and on a night like tonight all
my senses are on high alert I feel less
like a predator than prey truth be told
I'm almost always terrified of getting
caught of course we have our cover story
this man and I pretty standard we are
lovers if anyone asks what we're doing
together I said to him the first time we
met a few days earlier we're having an
affair
the old man nodded his head as if
ashamed as if we actually were having an
affair
supposedly he knew the routine
supposedly that is according to him he
too had been an intelligence officer for
the Yugoslav Internal Security Service
otherwise known as the secret police so
the man didn't bulk when I asked him to
meet me three nights later at the rear
exit of a shopping mall and he didn't
seem to find it strange the way I drove
us around taking one left turn better
for spotting cars behind you after
another until I finally found a near
empty parking lot behind some Soviet
style apartment apartment blocks he
probably even suspects that I'm wearing
a wig which I am my scalp gets itchy as
the humidity causes moisture to collect
between the mesh lining and my own hair
I want desperately to scratch but I know
it might make the lit the wig go
lopsided even if the man has guessed
that I'm in disguise I feel we ought to
maintain the charade in any event
there's a part of me that still wonders
if he's for real I take out a small No
pad and pen thinking most people would
be surprised to discover the primitive
nature of an average spies tools and I
turned to him you have information on
the whereabouts of Radovan Karadzic i
say in serbian the notorious serb
dictator slobodan milosevic had been
deposed but the CIA was still actively
pursuing many other persons indicted for
war crimes or piff wyx as we called them
among the most sought after balkan war
criminals was the former Bosnian Serb
commander Radovan Karadzic who had been
instrumental in the mass murder of
hundreds of thousands of Muslims a
campaign of ethnic cleansing in my naive
an eager state of mind I imagine that
with the help of this disheveled old man
I would bring the modern-day monster to
justice
I'd been overseas half a year waiting to
hook such a fish to do something
anything that would make my job seem
more worthwhile I was puzzled by the
pool of small-time targets that
headquarters and my CIA boss encouraged
me to pursue not to mention a bit
disillusioned by the actual banality of
being a spy turns out it was a lot of
paperwork this man who had volunteered
information by writing anonymously to an
intelligence officer somewhere else in
the world but who had agreed to meet me
in scope eeeh presented a real
opportunity for me to do something good
scope is the capital of Macedonia for
those of you don't know and Macedonia is
a small country in the Balkans for those
of you who don't know I don't think my
parents ever it was when I was there it
is through I have information on this
guy the man reached into his pocket into
the pocket of his crumpled overcoat for
what I could only hope would be a
diagram of the secret bunker in which
carriage and possibly even a few other
piff wicks I thought with mounting
anticipation were hiding but he pulled
out a pack of second-rate Yugoslavian
cigarettes having thought ahead I
produced from my own pocket some
superior American manufactured Marlboros
from which of which the men contentedly
partook one two light now a meaty
fistful more for later as you know we
are greatly interested in where
outs of mr. Karadzic I continued any
information you can provide that would
lead to his capture would of course be
duly rewarded I was thinking of the six
crisp $100 bills practically burning a
hole in my pocket
more than likely I would hand over this
money to the man at the end of this
meeting $600 was a pittance to the
agency I knew but it would indicate that
we meant business that there was more
where that came from if the man really
could lead us to carriage edge he stood
to earn hundreds of thousands of dollars
we might even help him and his family
relocate to the United States which I
assumed was his ultimate goal now I am
going to tell you said the man clearing
his throat I was on the edge of my seat
forgetting that now in the Balkans more
often meant never what the man wanted to
tell me as it turned out was not the
whereabouts of one of the CIA's most
wanted war criminals but the history of
modern Yugoslavia from his perspective
from the glorious birth industrious
lifetime and tragically untimely death
of Joseph bras Tito to the ill-fated
ascent of slobodan milosevic
and the destruction that he and his
cronies had wreaked upon what was once a
great nation he recited it all in
excruciating detail by the time we'd
reached modern-day Serbia it's
staggering inflation rampant poverty
general lawlessness and communal malaise
my excitement had eroded into total
annoyance I felt bleary-eyed
and nearly asphyxiated by secondhand
smoke but because there might be some
light at the end of the tunnel of this
man's blather i sat and listened for
hours in fact a couple of times I
restarted and relocated the car not so
much in order to heighten our security
as indeed I had been trained to do but
in the hopes that physical movement
might spur the man on meanwhile I kept
steering the conversation back to
carriage how do you know him I said the
man outlined at great length a
convoluted family neighbor former
colleague connection moments later he
conceded that he did not know Karadzic
personally at all does Karadzic know you
I asked he shrugged his shoulders and
pondered another unlit cigarette it is
possible yes it is also possible no look
sir I finally blurted out do you have
any idea where Karadzic actually is
right now ah he said smiling gingerly
cupping one hand over the other as he
lit his next cigarette now I am going to
tell you my head was itching like crazy
and I was finding it increasingly
difficult to mask my irritation as the
man sailed off on another historical
tangent initially I had admired the Serb
in my car for bravely coming forth and
volunteering information and for
refusing to accept any money at our
first meeting but I was fast growing
suspicious of him clearly the man had no
more clue where Karadzic was than did my
95 year old grandmother back at her
assisted living facility in New Jersey
no doubt word had spread that the CIA
was doling out big bucks for info and
the man obviously had come to cash in as
much as I hated to pay him for wasting
my time I realized that it was quite
possibly the easiest way to get rid of
him I glanced at the car clock its
digits growing glowing red through the
haze like dying embers of a fire it was
close to midnight
look I have to be honest with you I said
the names you provided me the other day
of your former colleagues and the secret
police well none of them checked out you
know we have records on who everyone is
your records are wrong the man said as
if the explanation were perfectly
obvious I had to admit that I probably
put even less face faith in the accuracy
of CIA data at that point then this guy
did of course I didn't tell him that the
point is I said my colleagues back in
Washington in other words my CIA boss
and scope eeya
aren't convinced that you are who you
say you are yota colleagues are idiots
he said suddenly agitated perhaps I said
but they're not such idiots that they're
going to pay for faulty information even
as I said it I knew it to be a blatant
falsehood the CIA I'd been discouraged
to discover paid for faulty information
all the time look it doesn't matter to
me who you are or what you do I said
either you know where carriages or you
don't if you do I'm prepared to show an
offer of our good faith
I made a minor production out of thumb
through the six crisp $100 bills if not
I will pay you for your time and let's
both be on our way
oddly the man refused to even look at
the bills I do not want your money he
cast his gaze toward the window as if
hurt or embarrass I just want to do what
is right
suddenly I felt sorry for him I looked
at his weather worn shoes his faces
craggy and hardened as a limestone cliff
and the tiny nub of a still lit
cigarette pinched between his
sausage-like fingers he probably had
been in the secret police I thought now
he was just some old man struggling to
make ends meet sadly I realized that as
much as I'd wanted this man to be
somebody he wanted it even more himself
why don't I Drive you back I finally
said next time we meet I am going to
tell you but then his voice just trailed
off at the rear of the shopping mall I
handed him $300 as was standard I had
him sign a receipt using a made-up name
this money which flowed like water
through the agency was government money
nonetheless and thus had to be accounted
for the man scrawled something across
the bottom of the scrap of paper I
handed him he folded the bills precisely
in half and slid them into the pocket of
his overcoat I will call you when I find
out some more he said but both of us
knew he would never call my boss didn't
care about the waste of time or even the
wasted money it's a good experience for
you he said to me later just as he'd
said about every other false lead and
the money represented but a drop in the
vast sea of agency excess an
incalculable waste anyway I rationalized
we'd bomb this guy's this poor guys
country just one year before to myself I
could justify the $300 as a kind of
random act of charity I did not watch
the man walk away into the shadows of
darkness for all I knew he'd
accomplished exactly what he set out to
do and perhaps there was a new bounce to
his step and his face bore a wide
self-satisfied grin for all I knew he
would fritter away that money on alcohol
and more cigarettes that was the thing
about being a spy there seemed to be so
little I could ever actually know
thank you um I hope there are some
question anyone we are ready to take
questions right let's start right back
here how many different languages did
you know uh that depends on how you
qualify no when I joined the agency I
spoke kind of what was designated as
Street Bulgarian and I knew French and
Italian and then the agency trained me
in serbo-croatian and when I went over
to live in Macedonia I learned to speak
Macedonian because it's very similar to
Bulgarian and the Macedonians had used
serbo-croatian for four years before
Macedonia became its own country so I
knew a bunch of different languages but
now they're all a mishmash in my head hi
what's the UM dangerous or scariest
situation you're ever in um probably the
scariest situation I was ever in I
described in the book and it was kind of
auxilary to being a spy it could have
happened to me under any circumstances
but I was um I was in Macedonia and I
was riding my bike actually I just
finished putting a chalk mark on a water
fountain so I guess it did have
something to do with being a spy
and at that time by way of background
Macedonia during the years that I was
there was kind of falling apart it had
been one of the few Balkan countries not
to break down into civil war but during
the time I was there it was on the verge
of civil war and three Macedonian
soldiers this kind of motley crew of
Macedonian soldiers mistook me for an
Albanian rebel and jumped into the
bushes and readied their ak-47s as I was
riding by on my bike and luckily I could
speak the language well enough that I
could stop and convince them that I
wasn't a member of the coast of our
liberation party but that was probably
the scariest thing that ever happened I
was just wondering if what you what the
finished project was was this about
what you intended and how much that you
had in there was actually taken out
through the cia's I guess process
process it was a lot longer when I
initially wrote it but most of the cuts
were mandated by my editor at Putnam not
by the CIA the CIA I have to say was
very fair
in my estimation in what they asked me
to take out you know I kind of had a
back-and-forth dialogue with the
publication Review Board
and everything that they asked me to
take out or change I did and there was
nothing that I felt like detracted from
the book the book is you know as I said
it's it's kind of kind of has a cheeky
tone and I had wondered if they would
make me take out parts of the book that
were either directly or indirectly
critical of the agency and they didn't
so I was I was pretty impressed by that
did you know you were going to write a
book and did you take notes or would
that have not been safe to do the
question if you didn't hear it was did
you know you were going to write a book
and did you take notes I didn't know I
was going to write a book I mean I had
always loved writing and one of the many
naivete is I had joining the agency was
this thought that I could be a spy and
in my spare time I would write short
stories or poetry or something like that
and then I quickly realized that a spy
doesn't have spare time but I never
expected to write a book about my
experience at the agency and I didn't
keep any notes and that that in fact
would have been considered a security
violation to have any notes on my person
that that spoke of my experience as a
spy what made you not stay in working
for the CIA and you're retiring what was
a reason um I left the agency for a
number of reasons and and some of them
were personal I I realized after I
became a spy in CIA terminology it's
called a case officer a lot of CIA
people bristle if you call a case
officer a spy but I'm using spy just
because I I think it's what most people
recognize
but I was found myself very
uncomfortable with what the actual
essence of being a spy is you can kind
of tell from the passage that I just
read that what you're doing is you're
you're praying upon foreigners a little
bit and trying to get them to give you
information and I found that I was very
uncomfortable from the get-go with this
notion of trying to get someone to do
something that I would never do which is
to betray my country or commit espionage
and trying to make a case that that was
in their best interests so on the
personal front I just realized that I
actually didn't enjoy being a spy and
didn't want to devote my life to that
and then on a kind of I guess
ideological front
I found the agency to be a very stifling
environment and I had thought that it
would be an environment that would
really foster independent thinking and
creativity and I found it to be just the
opposite and so there were a number of
disillusionment s' along the way
culminating probably with September 11th
which I viewed as the the biggest
intelligence failure certainly of my
generation and the agency sluggishness
in responding to that
what are your thoughts on the current
shake-up going on right now is it is it
going to help the agency you know I
would have been the first one to
advocate change at the agency but I
don't think that it's it's being
undertaken in the most graceful of
manners under Porter Goss I guess and
the few people that I've known who have
been purged ironically I thought they
were some of the best people that the
agency had another disillusionment that
I had with the agency toward the end of
the five years was this sense that the
organization was becoming increasingly
more partisan when I first joined the
agency I can say I give everyone who
worked their credit for really keeping
politics out of their work both on the
operations end and the analysts it tends
to be a kind of hawkish conservative
environment but I never saw anyone let
their personal political beliefs get in
the way of what their mission was
whether it be in operation or as an
analyst producing the best analysis they
could and I think I saw that change
particularly during the build-up to the
Iraq war when it seemed to me that the
agency had kind of been co-opted and was
being used as a tool by the
administration to achieve its agenda of
going to war so that was incredibly
disheartening to me and I think that it
it seems to be going more in that
partisan direction under Porter Goss
where there are many women colleagues
was it an old boys club so to speak it's
still very much an old boys club for
sure but I did have a number of female
colleagues in my training class I can't
say how many people were in my training
class but almost half of us were women
and in my estimation the best spies that
I knew were women the best case officers
that I knew the most successful the most
aggressive and I think the most
professional across the board were women
and
that was you know that was really
interesting for me to discover and in
part the subject of this article that I
wrote for Washingtonian but I think it
comes down to a lot of being a good spy
is relying on your intuition and I think
women are in general naturally very good
at being intuitive and reading people
and that that's 90 percent of the job in
your book you talk a lot about having to
lie to people in your life and I
especially are friends Emin Emily that
you still manage to spend time with and
I was just curious what the fallout for
you personally has been and if you've
had a lot of negative fallout from
people finding out the truth I've had I
guess more positive fallout from people
finding out the truth but I have
realized retrospectively that a lot of
people were angry at me during this this
sort of gap in my life where I wasn't in
touch with with anyone
and since I have you know come out I
guess
the a lot of friends have written to me
and said well I'm glad that I finally
know why we never heard from you
I had the sense when I was actually
going through it that I was losing these
friendships but I guess I didn't realize
how hurt people were by what I did which
was basically go incommunicado for four
five years I would do it again and
people ask me a lot would you recommend
it to anyone else a young man or woman
who was considering going into the
career of spy tum' and I would I really
would because I know for myself and my
parents can probably attest to the fact
that no matter how hard anyone tried to
discourage me from taking this path I
was intent upon doing it realizing that
it wasn't for me was something that only
I could do but I think that's something
if someone has that that itch
that they they have to scratch it
themselves I guess so and also the
agency desperately needs good people you
know I'm not the only one from my
training class who's left a number of us
have left
and I thought they were some of the best
people who ended up leaving in a very
short period of time just like I did and
that's a shame for that organization and
it's a shame for our country right over
here you familiar with the case of from
the Supreme Court now with the Soviet
witness protection and only if you had
any thoughts on that and and how strange
it is to enforce something like that
when you usually make a deal but it's
not really legal in the first place I'm
a little bit familiar with the case
she's referring to and for those of you
who are not I guess there's a case going
before the Supreme Court now where an
Eastern European correct me if I say
anything wrong but an Eastern European
couple who had been foreign agents
working for the CIA are now suing the
agency saying that the agency didn't
fulfill its end of the whatever bargain
they had and the agency is seeking to
quash the entire lawsuit saying that
these people don't even have a right to
bring this to court
I think this couple are American
citizens now because that's the the
nature of espionage or the nature of
spine you can never actually sue the
organization that you're spying for not
knowing a lot about the case you know I
don't know who's in the right or who's
in the wrong but I think there's a
danger of you know it's it's very hard
as a case officer as a CIA case officer
to recruit people under any
circumstances and it's increasingly hard
as America has become less and less
popular throughout the world something
like this makes it even harder and I'm
not blaming the couple or the agency but
a situation like this where if it does
emerge that the agency hasn't fulfilled
its end of the bargain to this couple
who obviously put their lives on the
line for the CIA and for our country it
kind of sends a message worldwide to
foreigners that perhaps it's not in
their best interest to work for us and I
think that that makes the job of every
CIA case officer even more difficult
and you sir have last question there's
two questions for me is that right have
you seen the movie the recruit and how
accurate is that of the farm I just
watched it the other day in fact for the
second time I watched it's a I mean it's
a ludicrously it's a looot kind of
ludicrous premise the whole movie but
the the actual scenes that take place
down at the farm are really accurate and
I think the movie although I would say
kind of a stupid movie really does a
good job of capturing like the mystique
of the farm I watched it with a former
colleague of mine who also had been to
the farm and and we were just amazed you
know that we both kind of got that same
sort of queasy but excited feeling
watching Colin Farrell I mean there's
nobody like Colin Farrell at the CIA for
sure but I'm watching a Colin Farrell
you know ride down on this school bus to
the find it really reminded us of what
we had gone through
no that was my Soviet okay all right
and if that is all the questions we have
we want to thank Lindsay for being here
this evening the book is called blowing
my cover my life as a CIA spy please
help me in thanking Lindsay Moran
Lindsay Moran is author of blowing my
cover my life as a CIA spy it's
published by Putnam on the web at
penguin com